Європа на троянд по конфлікту в
українці з ваших слив не зовсім зрозуміла
українців та недоліки і вимагала
українців за розкол та конфлікт на сході
україни у вигляді шов тисяч на інший план
для Європи з вашого приводу
я ким є за раз прийняття українців Європи
ми можемо вмовляти топ по ряду sin pro
кулі таки в Європи дуже складного
ви на стояку стака зальний суд же ніші
готовий окотив він встиг ства сусп листя
і Європи до нас ставиться
я так розумію що кулі так європи зуб
пройдусь їм та дати sopro європейський
спілка
вулицям сенсі все-таки чоловікові
демонстрантів та одну після посаду та
новачок що
погоні з тушонки з Росії та нас
проводи їх силоміць не панувати і в той
а година може влаштувати і політичну
зрілість вісь наступають на орла
своїм економічним пісням так он у тій
ж час заощадити ну месію зис-3 мула
не агресор і ось тут я дуже важливо
чоловіка іконками поле таємне наповнення
напади і ти top to stream уїїчі
агресора не з вини його задобрювати
провести чітку лінію будуємо звільнятися
увійшла його а задобрювання
з катастрофа тому що агресор hydra
адже людина себе на коні та й obtain
до його починати задобрювати та when i
dunno ескалацію на черв'ячий скувати
може і programdata так і випаду коли з
вашого поля до Європи пава давай сам
дяку за добре віче навчання конфлікті в
наших тіл конфлікту тощо.
ну я думаю що тут нас правді
європи покращувати свій канал про рівні
максимум як саме чоловіки кімнат
нами пам'ятають його ден абсолютно в перті
факт вин куля в тому що
палить на європейських краєм німа
дасть від нього розгорнутих скинутих сил
для того щоб вступати про ризикову
конфронтацію з росією і адже можна
його всі взяти та розумні t6 струнких сил
ненавидь аза петренко американських
струнких посилання випадково вже менше
розмиву
їм shat em a алое виходить через 3
факту шоу з брайном та
пішли хами через конфлікт нічого
гарного на та досягнуті зараз тільки
на локальний максимум
мені здається що нас правді та даний
момент століттями я таки здався в критій
з історія напруження
малайзійського боїнгу я коли мені палять
мало ви ікла ти просто значно означає
бур клавішу чистки шоу реакцію а чоловікові
його в тому куля це специфіка
європейську та ментальності
трушці б холоду сирин правда правда вул
його на страшно вся правда то поспішаю
настою така реакція розумниці цінним сіон
і може but i ціни так центри брус
слідувати його серце треба раз слідів від
і всередині залишається за це довго там вуса
відразу мило посміхнувся тримай
так почали почали статися знають риси
шанс ви шари снуд і цін нас правдиво не
здається такий вона і солодкий шайа історія
у сіону конфлікті
панеллю засвоєний сюди за кулон сенат
dv вистежувала не база бігати матчем
angelov сима нинішнього та європейського акри
за ми просто жити опорний
апокаліптичний сценарій сторони та
які реалізується владимиром путіним
чому безглуздо пісні the city's і я дуже
пам'ятаю той стан
ну окей ринок тут
віддаленості руки в тему свині засіки в
Європі та яким чудово ми фактично
щасливим дивувалась ця дима будні
або відкривалася a prospective та я кобла
віра підкріплена владно здаються фактами
в т.ч.
європа від страшного
перспективні це дуже арі потужний
успішний проект і по переду у нас звучать
у проблема то ви пробування ми
абсолютно успішно з відвезу since then
порадував і вся ситуація на яскравість так
змінює селектор на момент утоп, то я
починаю на лізу лати
акули в cs вигляд знову повернулася атак а
ось велика глобально трагедія вісь ми
вивчаємо і можемо у який світильник
виставить 11 на 1 5 тисяч пар широкого
колиму zeiss вигляд повернув зі смоли про
святого вину ось ще на пивній можу
сказати з самого початку що в
дев'яності руки знак ітема доступні
святого івеною а починаючи за донат 102
тисяч прошу руку тотема power таїться та
вона буває з руками у великих і
великих братів і вісь можна його ви
підкова можна його не алли починаючи за
1000 руку президенту дуже спливла ви і
все-таки
натиснули у теми suite країни зграя людей на
таке я з нічною першою підв'язую
цех та і power мене теж хіт клуб
приїжджає пеклі не матч єнот за крима за
раз на літературному фестивалі
дактильно ви зрозуміло собою акт листа
ніякі пошуки я більше the chef абу у
розме це себе я коли нас плавну та до
логічну місію не джона муразе я боюся
відсік сливи та бою зі слова ідеологія та
то тому що паїсія на люблю-цілую
слова та
і слова місія це я виживаю цю
невелику кімнату ж іронічним смислом
фестиваль та такі шви стоцький тупи
письмовий з
баток краєм і ми говоримо про і кисті
маяки складно
прямо і слава богу прив'язати до
політики диво ідеологій вікна приклад ну
добре тієї мотивів їсть еволюції для у так
топ то я сказати синьому глибині
втомлюються кольори і все його символічніше
значення і вид ось цьому я тут води не
стик хто приїхав за своїм відваром і зі
своїми текстами і я поважаю що
спилку кучерявого з еньші ми до зміни кон
в.с.
німецьку публіку і тут можна вони слова
на
гаряче політику можна викладається
таки з'явилася політична робота
панеллю революційний дух майдан і вже
хіба я вся повністю креслення такий рахунок
бачимо пагорб
потрібен брата за втратила нас правді я
сумніваюся цьому нібито від вуха у людях
енергії ну волонтерський рук нам не
пам'ятають знайдено спад активісти займаються
то нічого полину позики тобто активісти
адже органи глади включаються в
їх але реальність так що можна сказати і
так порох у порохівницях також мали
метою залучити з на quality не про гори
на прага злодія у верховній раді всі сто
суеца децентралізації констатаційний
змін ви бачать ще українські політики
допускаються цих самих помилок загальної
політики листа паршиво майдану так
сцені забарвлення зі значно після не стригти
ніші нижчі через дух майдану та
активістом та волонтери mike 1
політики в кадр і вдома будувати свою
не виявляюсь загазованістю
у владних російських інтересах та
абсолютно чітко прочитується
і хочеться бути злим пророком вона не
здається тут у роті сказати іван та планів
закінчити його видує якщо вона просто
багатьом грому донскова з встигнувши твоїх і
прийшли за раз у політику задавала не ви
результатом та їх роботи засіки
журналістів задоволений і ціни ті слова
алея
думаю що з схвалить краще що ось цьому
побачення можна так важливо ти все-таки
завелася зі своєю рідною
агенти романської істоти на побачення
tieyi просто кошмарна структура і до
називається парламентом чому ви маєте рацію і
ви таз і б/у політати і не я важу я
дамага і стати я вас вбила таки
великий і кумис страшному сні
ось я поважаю що можеш значно
найефективніше на ній впливла ти
хто перебуває поза дорогою ким і
політичними структурами завищуй вчити
просто індивідуально
найсухіший Сергій жаданий мар'яна
садівська їздити на донбас а
їздить я мало цих високих 3-го лише їх у
турі виступив вали
веселий що ми станемо шансом довелося а
париже ти був в 1 разу з концертами з
виступом маріуполь маріуполь
я каже там тошно мішкан синя донбаса
приазов'я ну в кожному разі
це дуже близько до лінії фронту за
кілька руки до кривавих піди на сході
України
висловив ще бомба сцени української
території та крим також я пропускався я
тримав
алло алло я свічку увійти в за раз
духовний звук з донбасом чого рб оборот
ася зації території
я думаю що диму я таких територій
просто території зайчика
у роті
пусти ну проливати кров і боротися з
нами пам'ятають не про територію вимагали
то про людей
збувається в головах і в душах і сцен
раніше ну такі виставки погоні
території можна класти висновок і вона села
немає і портулак
так ось такі варіант хто його хоче їх
то поважаю його реальними вони і я не хотів
б шуб ми вкрай бувало секіс
депортації я каша в головах та в душах
людей і боїться все на світі крем крем
україни якушева ний
не на те й чураїв скажемо так свою суперечку
нанести знаю я поважаю чоловік вивіз
проведення там ніколаса референдуму для
теж всі люди взяв і вигляд по дальності
за свою частку за свої мої будні і самі
вирішила цього рішення з ким вона хоче
ніби я думаю htc так че і наші такі
Особливо перспектива і нікуди видно
і на шляху тис по духу і що
змінилося для вас усунути цю масу
за вуста не
булочка 2 роки новина на приклад я
познайомився з точністю такого за ціною
на до владимира росіянка росіянку
притаманні польші російську нову ленка
вишнім ніжками донецька вину тягачі з
донецька
жив етапи руки та центру червоний листи
так осі я просто захід ви не вели війну
мішуру мало
називається цілі роман довгота днів я був
у здається водними старших читачі вождь
я знаю формі та видане книжки у формі
рук досвіду і з тією moon and the і випаду
cool та
листі на свою креативність так
знатні все-таки займе це поза
втомився і на поневіряння сторін ти з цього
ми не здається і за дик ції книжки врахував
гуртки і наша спадкова це seal it all
its principal для мене з острова вигода
я так що ми можемо говорити про Україну
взятих людей про сус чи українець
посилював крима взятих людей, а в душі
складно
будь-які ти донбас як давно цю масу
населення так чого він шлюбу я зараз у
українські політики тимур фону за ват і
водні 2
на 2 промов яких би вам хотілося на увазі
українських політиків через те, що вам
про queen ну мені шлюбу адже я при
дальності затушеваний звільнити і рейд по
видно stiu тому шоу на горі тиші потім
рублів з 2 розрахунок і дальності
ліквідність так схилися геть і
нами погляд за боготу уго визначальні з
ній
ефектнішою фразі он і абсолютно не
реалістично висувається для потокової
ситуацію і в той же час своїм ідеям
ізолюють осіб куди віру та вісь
закрита довіра його на я була так і
завищується таким головним як ті й
наші плиткові sistar та